hey guys Dimitri Pascal una here from
the score esports with hundreds of
heroes and items to choose from and
endless ways of combining them the
beauty of dota 2 lies in its
sophistication that said some of the
hypest moments in the game's competitive
history are when one player kills
another mano V mano but Thompson he's
actually got the damage damage miss
uphill is it going to happen no it
doesn't decrepit fight he just has to
wait
he has been an absolute genius so that's
why this week we've decided to count
down the top ten solo kills in the
history of professional dota 2 now when
we say solo kill we mean when one player
takes out another regardless of how many
heroes are in their vicinity so now that
that's out of the way let's get on with
the list coming in at number 10 is
Thompson's pugna's styling on PSG LGD b
SG e ol DD vs. o
in TI eights upper bracket final the
finish mid laner managed to hide himself
in the trees while the rest of his team
retreated luring LGD into a false sense
of security
so while amazed thinks he's safe under
the guise of his shadow blade nothing
could be further from the truth
May's up to with a dire sense reward
revealing the enemy drow Ranger tops and
deletes lgd's carry in an instant before
blinking out retreating and of course
taunting his opponents coming in at
number nine is crits dark willow solo
kill from the Stockholm major it was a
series of unfortunate events for a yeast
poor puck here and there was simply
nothing he could do to stop any of them
from occurring that's the 50 Women of
Hope oh not at all this
Brandon's done he's gone critters all
all Oh killed a puck I forgot why I hate
to disturb you so much in my pubs with
crits you'll scepter setting up the
bramble roots and the following curse at
crown stunned dark willows perfectly
layered lockdown ensures there's no way
out for the enemy puck it just goes to
show that even a position for support
can take out a mid laner if done
properly it's not wise to stand in my
way our number 8 solo kills see spam
favor Dendi showing he still got what it
takes to keep up with the scenes young
guns bendy
[Music]
not only does he win an unfavorable lane
matchup but he's doing it against one of
the best ember spirits in the world
this trial is just way stronger tryna
pretend e-verify is it gonna be enough
no it's no Dendi with the outbreak with
his early level advantage Dendi puts all
his points into increasing the damage of
his illusory orb and waning rift
completely catching mid-1 off-guard
remember kids MMR is just a number
Opeth nd finding his way at the number 7
spot is miracles tinker who puts on an
absolute clinic against team secret
miracle starts this one off in style
securing an easy solo key L'Enfant has
axe before quickly returning back to
base to refill his mana dancing in and
out here playing with a miracle doing
taker things as he finishes off Potter I
get another solo kill as we go back
towards with a full mana pool he
teleports top lane and finds another
easy pick on gap Sora's Windrunner but
now with only 4 heroes they can't defend
this tier to its another objective going
away of liquid it now yaks or gets
caught miracle is just everywhere that
was unfortunate coming in at number 6 is
this classic solo kill on burnings
Weaver courtesy of mushi
with three of his teammates taken out
just seconds earlier mushi and his last
surviving ally are in full retreat or so
it seems he's gonna wait for the surge
it's level two with the high ground
advantage mushi channels his Requiem of
souls and times it perfectly with the
invisible bug reaching the high ground
before burning even has a chance to
react mushi hits him with one final
shadow raised to finish him off that's
one for the history books
up next in number five is South American
player Bardo who pushes dark willow to
new levels of [ __ ] after losing all
their barracks and going up against mega
creeps infamous decides to go all-in and
end the game with a rapier on their
insanely farms Tara blade the only thing
standing in their way
a measly position five support dark
willow give them a little run to safety
Tara Blake and receive all the damage
that dark willow has to offer what a
balance erosion astray kills on the
divine rapier on the floor all right
dark willow ok divine rapier is gone
there goes the chances for infamous
seriously who needs items when you're
this good at spell-casting parlor tricks
don't impress me terribly
we couldn't do this top 10 list without
including whee-ha and his infamous
invoker Sun strikes he tries to go for
the target joy come on Lucy Lucy's dead
as well the TV on 343 will complete it
but that's three
he got him with a Sun strike the Sun
strike were highlighting seas we ha
start things off by bullying mid-1 and
forcing his drow ranger out of lane 3
behind deafening blast is not enough the
triple rape after a long walk back to
the fountain mid-1 thinks he's made it
home free all the while keeping a
careful eye on we for when he casts sun
strike Mike cub strike is up he's
watching we hi Ben
unfortunately in an attempt to dodge the
spell mid one ran right into it
we hot do you miss every Sun strike you
don't throw simply find me through
coming in at number three is hosts first
blood clutch in the final game of the
international three
what's chaos tonight for the final game
both international number three both
teams trying to go home with 1.4 million
dollars and of course the love the aegis
of that that what matters a line started
us off with an early aggressive dive in
the bot lane on Havas solo safe lane
alchemist bottom lane for both on the
rug gets pulled into another he's
channeling a stun but he's been locked
in position
dropping fans not yet
[Music]
simply too damn good now that's what I
like to call work coming in at the
runner-up spot is Ferrari 430
insane solo kill on our ot K's
broodmother we had to dig deep into the
dota 2 archives for this one but damn is
it ever worth it when you get a play as
sexy as this arts again runs back in
though that might be channeling his
inner Jedi Ferrari bounces his attacks
off enemy lane creeps guessing where his
invisible opponent may be and he lands
every single shot my blades and my mind
are as one taking the number one spot on
our list is none other than miracle and
he's godlike invoker solo kill on you
nines juggernaut at da sea 2017 upper
brackets for victims
[Music]
mirakl hides himself in the tree line
while letting his forged spirits push
the tier 2 Tower after the tower falls
u9 uses his spin to clear the wave and
quickly retreat with his shadow blade
but miracle has other plans
confident he's caught the invisible
juggernaut miracle follows up his
tornado with a Sun strike deafening
blast combo that decimates newbies carry
the only one not surprised is miracle
himself let's watch that one more time
for miracles perspective to show just
how insanely good this ti winner really
is I don't know if they really wanted to
commit into the tier one either so but
yeah let's take that beautiful combo
well guys that's our list please like
the video subscribe to our Channel and
let us know in the comments what other
dota 2 related top 10s you'd like to see
see you next time thanks for watching if
you want more content like this hit the
sub button and ring that notification
bell for unique bite-sized videos you
will find anywhere else hit up our
Instagram Twitter & Facebook pages